[Music]
hello time then for the press preview
it's our first look at tomorrow's front
pages and we'll check out the headlines
tonight with jenny clement and
christopher hope they'll be with us from
now until just before midnight a very
good evening to both of you we'll chat
in a second after we've had a look at
those front pages starting with the
daily telegraph opening with boris
johnson urged to make hunt chancellor
claiming that the prime minister's
allies are pushing for a dream team in
an attempt to heal the party
well the daily express says the prime
minister is fighting back with plans for
major tax blitz to silence rebels
on a similar theme the times says
cabinet ministers are demanding tax cut
action if the prime minister wants to
survive
while the guardian says tory mps are
plotting vote strikes to paralyze law
making and keep boris johnson on the
ropes
total rail shut down proclaims the metro
reacting to the news that 50 000 members
of the rmt union are poised to strike on
three days later this month with
widespread disruption expected
similarly the daily mail says the action
will paralyze britain in the biggest
strike since 1989.
the daily mirror asks can't someone sort
this out warning of a continued summer
of chaos for holidaymakers
while the ft leads with ukrainian
president vladimir zelinsky insisting
that a stalemate with russia is not an
option and reiterating his appeal to
western governments for military support
on a different note the daily star looks
towards a weekend of storms and sneezing
citing high pollen counts as well as
thunder
and don't forget that by scanning the qr
code you can see on screen join the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
listen to us discussing them and i'm
joined tonight by jenny clement and
christopher hope jen it's lovely to see
you again first time for what is it two
years
to be back jonathan great and we're
going to make sure your microphone is on
as well so we hear every word uh and
christopher lovely to see you too as
well um jenny as it's your uh debut
after such a long time why don't you
kick things off for us um what a what a
24 48 hours it has been um the front
page of the daily express are ever
optimistic when it comes to boris
johnson their headline fighting back
boris's tax blitz to silence rebels um
let me get your reaction first of all to
last night's vote
well i think it was pretty appalling for
boris johnson and i think he knows it no
matter how much uh he and his closest
allies have tried to spin it sometimes
in quite orwellian terms as some sort of
victory it's a disaster for him it's
it's everything that his uh opposition
uh would have wanted in terms of him
being mortally wounded uh but limping
onwards
um it means that either 70 percent of
his backbenchers uh want him to go don't
support him or it's a a lesser
proportion and some of his ministers uh
don't have any confidence in him so it's
it's disastrous
sorry to interrupt jenny i was just
going to say none of them have gone
today does that surprise you that there
hasn't been more of a reaction
well i think that uh
boris johnson has deliberately chosen to
surround himself uh in terms of the
cabinet and and ministers with biddable
people that aren't going to challenge
him he doesn't necessarily bring people
who have the the most experience and the
most insight into the highest position
of government he brings people who are
loyal to him so it doesn't surprise me
that people haven't gone because he's
chosen people purely for their loyalty i
think um but
what saddened me i think was to hear his
statements cabinet today which wasn't
contrite he was saying that the results
was was decisive and conclusive and it
shows that he still isn't listening he
wasn't listening to the boos at the
weekend he wasn't listening to the votes
against him he keeps robotically
repeating this mantra about moving on
and drawing a line and whilst the daily
express i mean lord love them you know
they love the government they're always
going to put a positive spin on things
no matter what but this was the vagus
word salad of promises a massive agenda
tax cuts were going to cut taxes but we
didn't hear uh what there is a lack of
direction in this government they are
out of ideas the ideas that they have
some of them have been nicked from the
labour party like the windfall tax some
of the ones announced today where boris
johnson was saying government
departments have to be more efficient
than ever before this was announced
weeks ago and this ridiculous
announcement today about how it's going
to be an nhs for the for the netflix era
what on earth does that mean are we
going to be paying a subscription it's a
word salad a word salad uh christopher
um certainly wounded then uh jenny is
saying but can he fight his his way out
of this um as the as the daily express
suggests
well of course you can fight out of this
and much as jenny may not want to be the
case of course you can fight out of this
uh time is on his side he's got a year
to get this back on track um the 1922
committee might change the rules to
allow another no confidence vote uh in
the meantime but as jenny knows all the
letters given to graham brady the 54
plus the rest have now gone into his
filing uh cabinet and it's wiped clean
the state is clean and boris johnson can
fight back and that's all he can do and
all the express is doing is is reporting
what he told a cabinet what jenny is may
be saying is there's not enough
real detail here um it's a lot of vague
pledges that we've heard before about
cutting spending and trying to find a
way to cut taxes and and we at the time
of see the same thing we want to see
more actual um more conservative type
policies with the many people thought
they were electing when he was elected
prime minister i was there
last night uh in in in parliament in the
actual room in the front row of the
press team when graham brady announced
his result it was quite extraordinary
the first half of the room bang the
tables so the whips you can see the back
half of the room where i sat 50 or so
toy mps they all sat in there on their
hands they were not impressed it was a
big big defeat it's a long way back for
boris johnson it was a dramatic moment
christopher just staying with you i want
to bring in the guardian um because you
can say that he's going to he's going to
fight on but there's no doubt about it
those rebels are going to keep fighting
as well and the guardian's got an
interesting take
tory mps plot vote strikes in order to
uh to keep him on the ropes
yes
that's one idea and that of course would
meet would see the whip being withdrawn
the whips will get quite tough i mean it
does seem quite extraordinary those of
us who had to slug our way through the
brexit wars of 2018
2019 to see these vote strikes coming to
the fore again
i'm not quite sure what the point of all
this is because there's no real person
to to unite behind jeremy hunt came out
quite early yesterday saying a vote for
change without saying he's standing for
leadership although everyone thinks he
is by the way um but what but why why go
on strike why damage um the tories even
more why why hemorrhaging defeat i met a
senior labour per a really senior labor
person today
he told me how he was amazed that um
nadine doris had attacked jeremy hunt
on twitter by saying that he hadn't been
prepared properly for the pandemic and
he was saying her labour are going to
screen grab all of these points and they
are the attack lines for the next
election and that's why it's a worry if
you look at the top of the guardian
there marina hyde the brilliant
columnist saying now watches the
conservatives eat themselves well they
are i call themselves a boxer literally
punching themselves in the face while in
the same ring label look on going up to
you guys keep doing it yeah jenny you're
nodding away
yeah i mean this has echoes of of you
know the the last few months of of the
major government of sleaze of decadence
of of division of of infighting of the
tory party eating itself and you know we
need really big bold ideas in a time of
crisis we don't need suggestions of
returns to imperial measures and attacks
on the bbc
we don't have any of that at the moment
and and uh you know and the the northern
ireland issue is a really big problem
that we we haven't managed to to to
solve and the idea that there is going
to be a backlash when voting on this
bill in order to make a political point
really lets down the people of northern
ireland i would say
um jenny when it comes to so sorry yeah
jump back in christopher
well i'm not sure that's quite right i
think the idea of precious bill this
null the island protocol bill as soon as
tomorrow or thursday is exactly what he
needs to do to sort the brexit issue out
when he bursts through that um wall of
bricks at the jcb factory saying he's
going to get brexit done many tories
supported him on that very basis now
brexit is not done for people living in
northern ireland that needs resolving
and the hope is it can be shortly
um jenny you talked about bold ideas
this would be a bold idea wouldn't it
making jeremy hunt chancellor as the the
front of the the daily telegraph is
discussing
yes there's no sense of where this
suggestion came from maybe christopher
can give us some detail on that or
whether or not jeremy hunt would accept
given the position that he's taken his
criticisms of boris johnson but it's
this idea of of keep your enemies close
keep your friends close and your enemies
closer um what is remarkable in all of
this is that apart from jeremy hunt
there is no obvious leadership contender
to challenge boris johnson with no
organized rebellion which is what makes
uh the the margin of his his victory his
pyrrhic victory yesterday so remarkable
because there was no one whipping or
galvanizing people to to to to give a
vote of no confidence
uh this will um embolden potential
successors and it will also embolden the
those reluctant yeses yesterday jeremy
hunter's the only person who who's
really um
putting his head above the parapet in as
much as as anybody does in this
situation risky rishi spinach seems to
be kind of mortally wounded at the
moment uh i don't know whether or not he
would accept being chancellor uh i think
he probably has bigger ambitions well he
turned down a job christopher didn't he
after after the leadership election uh
uh last time i think they were gonna he
was asked if he wanted to be defense
secretary where has this idea come from
in the telegraph
well it's clearly an idea which during
the rounds boris johnson met with senior
um
team senior mps um while mps are voting
before the vote last night in his
private rooms behind the speakers jai
and the commons and they were urging him
to go for a reshuffle and be bold um the
view on richie sunak is he had a good
pandemic he's been badly damaged by the
non-dom row badly damaged by his own
green card which he gave up
quite recently and his wealth
sadly is now seems a damaging thing
rather than the positive thing which
some toys might view it as so for those
reasons also he did break the manifesto
pledge by putting up national insurance
by uh 1.25 for those reasons he is seen
as the most obvious person to move in a
reshuffle in which case who goes in um
as chart chancellor liz trust is an
option but jeremy hunt is a new idea and
that might unite the the the party don't
forget jeremy hunt fought the 19 um
leadership campaign on unite to win and
that's what the party needs to do now it
needs to unite to win and maybe bring
hunt into the fold is one option yeah
fascinating stuff
welcome back to part two of the press
preview jenny and christopher still with
me uh let's talk about the uh the travel
chaos that we're suffering at the moment
and uh is there's more on the way
front of the financial times summer of
misery looms as airports face staff
squeeze and rail union strike front of
the metro as well total rail shutdown um
jenny this is miserable isn't it it
could be the biggest industrial action
since 1989 on the railways
yes and i think unless you've got a
bicycle uh you're not going to be
traveling very far this summer very
easily i would say
there's three separate things in play
here one there's the problems in the
aviation industry the chief executive uh
of uh i think it's heathrow airport has
told the uh ft that um it's gonna take
12 to 18 months to get things back up
and running uh
because of you know lots of people laid
off during the pandemic
tens of thousands of jobs
were cut from the aviation industry and
it's really struggling as as passengers
want to travel
again and that is coupled with this news
on the 21st the 23rd and the 25th of
june there are planned strike strikes
from the rmt and the news that it costs
it's going to cost about 100 pounds to
fill up an average car with unleaded uh
petrol uh and inflation already at a
nine year high anyway um it's it's a
really bad summer uh to be making travel
plans yeah christopher what do you what
do you think of the
the rmt's move they're saying it's over
pay compulsory redundancies safety
concerns as well um you know they've had
a real issue with pay especially given
that inflation is is so high
well the knockout effects have already
been felt by these dates that came out
tonight the daily mail have put them on
put them on page one um touring nikki
yaikin i know is worried about the fact
that these will fall around the same
times as gcses she'll have a lot of
students who go by by train to get to
school can't take their gcses would you
believe it after having two years of
misery
taking exams at home or in controlled
conditions or not at all because of the
pandemic now they can't even get to
school to take their exams result this
will cause chaos for millions it comes
at a time when the government is trying
to get more of us back on the rail
commute to work five days a week if you
can um you know take trips away at the
weekend because it's so heavily
subsidised the idea was to make them
cut expect cut the cost of of running
the network trying to try and make it
more sustainable well that that's the
idea behind it but the unions aren't
happy about it
and jenny just let's finish with this
story of the front of the guardian the
legal age of smoking could go up to 21.
these are yes this is uh new proposals
that are going to be discussed the legal
age of smoking to go out go up to 21 and
new taxes to be imposed on tobacco
companies
it's one of these things that sounds
like a good idea although i would i
wonder um how many people are smoking
who would be deterred by the legal age
being moved up to 21 now we know that uh
smoking uh is is at quite a low level
comparatively compared to a a couple of
decades ago and whether or not those who
are smoking now would be would be
deterred by uh that change is another
thing but you know in my view anything
make it harder it's a good thing we're
gonna have to leave you there we'll
speak again in a couple of minutes jenny
chris thank you